as the post-credits scene in Avengers
infinity war and the final few minutes
of her recently released solo movie have
proven Captain Marvel is like the Kim
Possible of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe call her beeper if you want to
reach her major Marvel fans know the
story SHIELD agent Nick Fury paged
Captain Marvel at the tail end of
infinity war after Thanos snapped his
infinity stone powered fingers and
killed half of all life in the universe
in Captain Marvel said many years
earlier carol danvers hands fury his
pager back before she leaves earth to
help the scrolls locate a new homeworld
telling him she made extra special
enhancements to his trusty
communications device and to only use it
to contact her when there's a quote real
emergency happening Thanos decimating
the universe is certainly a real
emergency no one denies this but what
about all the other crises that have
gone down in the MCU did they not
necessitate a call to Captain Marvel why
exactly did theory wait until infinity
war two-pager
we finally know the answers to all those
questions sort of movie news site slash
film did the world a favor when they
asked Marvel Studios President Kevin
Feige in a recent interview why fury
didn't contact Captain Marvel sooner
like say when that gigantic wormhole
barked up a bunch of aliens over
Manhattan in the original Avengers that
event was so bad that the world security
council launched a nuclear bomb at the
city Nick Fury had to run outside and
fire an actual bazooka at one of
shield's own planes to try to stop it
that's some rough stuff if Captain
Marvel is the most powerful character in
the MCU and if she's apparently strong
enough to help take down Panos why
hasn't she been spoken about in
connection with the Avengers until now
why hasn't she helped them out according
to Feige there are two explanations the
first one is that Fury may not have
considered anything that went down
before infinity war a genuine emergency
based on the scale of the chaos aliens
invading Manhattan who cares it's just
one city right no big deal
killer robots threatening total world
domination whatever that sounds like
something Tony Stark should be able to
fix with a quick call to his IT guy
at OIG have you tried turning it off and
on again Nick Fury actor samuel
l.jackson backed Feige on this
particular explanation chatting with IGN
about why Fury hasn't called Captain
Marvel before we finally have an
emergency that I feel warrants her
presence like this is something that's
unprecedented and you know I mean how do
you fight that fog ease second
explanation is a little hairier
according to the interview Feige
discussed Fury's super pager saying how
do you know he never hit it how do we
know he never pushed it before we've
never seen him push it before that
doesn't mean he never did okay maybe
that's true we never saw him pager but
there's a lot of things we never saw
Nick theory do we never saw him get
eaten by a shark but it doesn't really
make sense to accept that well perhaps
he did anyway it doesn't make too much
sense to speculate about the ins and
outs of why Fury may or may not have
called his BFF Captain Marvel over all
these years
that's because Avengers end game which
will fly into theaters next month well
probably address Captain Marvel's
whereabouts in the time between her solo
film and the end of infinity war not
only that but it should also explain why
the heck she didn't rush to the aid of
Earth's Mightiest Heroes when they
weren't feeling all that mighty and hey
maybe she'll show off some of the pages
Nick Fury did send her over all those
years maybe he kept her up to date with
those cool Star Wars prequels she was
missing while she was flying around in
space did send me little Jack's
asked for purple light sleep you bet
your ass I did
Avengers endgame opens in theaters on
April 26th perhaps before then Marvel
will release a montage of all the times
fury tried and failed to get Captain
Marvel to swoop in to save the day
a Marvel fan can dream check out one of
our newest videos right here Plus even
more lucrative about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]